there you go
thank you
so
it's a long title and essentially
it's going to be a new perspective on
garbling
so you can see new garbling
i'm starting with a motivational picture
this is the
geocentric model for the solar system
you can see the earth
in the middle
the sun should be here rotates around
and some planets do these funky orbits
but if you so it's a complicated system
but if you change perspective
it looks pretty clean
and
so we're going to do the same for
garbling
um
so the idea is we have
you know what happened to the first guy
there's a guy
yeah
so
he was also italian
so we're going to suffer a bit but it's
going to be a cool 400 years after 400
years after you can gonna you're gonna
garble pretty easily so the idea is in
400 years you're gonna garble just using
linear algebra essentially linear
garbling can be compared to linear
speaker sharing
and we show that simple properties imply
simulation-based security in other words
you have simulation proofs without
simulation proofs essentially it's a
kind of a neat idea
why do we need this it's essentially
because
a simpler
framework allows you to build more
advanced schemes and i'll show you a
more advanced scheme later on
okay
so
what is garbling
i give you a circuit if you garble a
circuit you get
some encoding information the actual
garbled circuit which is
what
the aak people call the offline encoding
and some decoding information
what you do with encoding is you take an
input you garble it and you get a
garbled input
then you can evaluate it via the garbled
circuit into a garbled output and then
you can decode it and get a value
if the garbled scheme is correct you
have that this diagram commutes meaning
it's equivalent to compute in the clear
or in the garbold
version of the circuit
and security
is uh simulation based we're following
the bellare horn and rogue away paradigm
so essentially you want to
simulate
the blue and the green things so the
garbled circuits and the garbled input
and also the decoding via just knowing
the circuit and the output so maybe i
can write down
you want to garble
green
this is the important part
good
so the focus of this talk will be on
boolean circuits
and i'm gonna talk about communication
complexity so
essentially mike gave me a very good
introduction to what i'm going to talk
about so i'm going to borrow his
scoreboard
he listed a lot of schemes and he listed
the communication complexity they
achieved
in terms of uh
lambda bits
so lambda is the security parameter as
you can see the one the scheme with
minimal
communication complexity is the half
gates paper by sammy mike and
david yes i remember the surname
so
can you do better
the answer is
well
if you want to garble using something
that is called linear garbling and you
garble gate by gate the answer is no
they prove that the stream is optimal
but then
you can circumvent this uh lower bound
just having not gate by gate schemes or
not linear schemes in this talk i'm
going to talk about not gateway gate
schemes they're still linear
maybe in the end i'll talk about
nonlinear
so
our scheme is not gay by gate and the
way we approach it is by slicing the
circuit in units and then garbage
garbled unit by
unit a cool feature of the scheme is
that
if you cut the circuit into gates you
get the half gate paper
but if you have bigger units
it's hard to prove simulation based
security therefore we invented this new
framework that
allows you to prove things easier more
easily
good so i told you not gate by gate now
i'm going to describe what linear means
and this is the slide to remember
it's
it's uh it took me a lot of time to
write
so intuition the garbler and the
evaluator just do two things they call
their numerical and then perform linear
functions so i'm the garbler what do i
do i sample some random values a vector
of random values
i call the numerical because i can do
that i append these results
at the bottom of my vector random
variable and i call this vector s
and then i do the other thing that i can
do which is apply linear functions and
which means i just
apply a matrix to us
and this is going to be the
garbling so you get the
encoding information
this is these are the output wires c0
and c1 and the garble circuit
what happens next is
while the encoding procedure applies the
encoding is nothing but a projection
that projects the encoding information
into the encoded the garbled inputs you
can think of this
here as being the whole set of input
labels and the green
part is just the active labels
okay so i'm now the evaluator down here
what do i do same thing i apply the
random oracle
somewhere
and
it turns out that
the random oracle calls that the
evaluator performs
are just a subset of what the
garbler performs it's a it's non-trivial
but
kind of intuitive
which means that i can write down this
vector as a matrix that i call g
times the original
vector s
so i called the random article what do i
do next
i apply a linear combination
and
the idea is i get the correct output
label by just
applying a linear combination of
this vector here
good so this is the
definition of linear garbling
there is a let's call it heliocentric
view on this which is
well instead of doing this which is
projecting and then calling the random
oracle and expanding
let's do the other way around let's
expand first so i just copy paste the
calls
that the garbler does here nobody
performs these operations by the way
it's it's just a thought experiment
and then a project
it's a commutative diagram again you can
go
right and down or down and right
why do i want to go right and down
instead of down and right
it's because this is very similar to
secret sharing
so secret sharing is this um
the person who shares has a random
vector let's call it s
multiplies it by a matrix let's call it
f
and this is the set of shares
and
given a subset of these
um let's call it this is going to be gs
you can perform a linear combination on
the
subset of shares and get
the secret back
um
yeah so it's essentially the same here
this is the full specification of all
the set of shares this is the subset of
shares that are given to the evaluator
and this is the secret that is
shared
in other words
a linear garbling scheme is nothing but
a secret sharing scheme for both outputs
and
this g matrix
defines what the evaluator sees so the
shares given to the evaluator
the blue shares are fixed for both
outputs
and the green part will determine if you
get one label or the other
um
yeah
so that's that's the intuition so
you have if you remember this everything
else will be
easy
good so now i'm gonna talk about
something that is familiar to you which
is yao but i will interpret it in this
notation
so i'm gonna move on the other side
actually for practical reasons
um
so
what does the garbler do in the yao
garbling
he samples
uniform labels for
a gate let's say it's an and gate and
then computes
the garbling information according to
the semantics of the gate
so
as you you can implement it as a linear
combination of
hash calls and
the random variables c0 and c1
in other words
the m matrix looks like this
this is the m matrix the m matrix was
this
and um
yeah so the second one the full
definition of what garble means
and um
yeah it doesn't look very good but
uh fine
um
yeah
could close it all
okay so this is the full specification
of the garbling for an end gate
and then i'll move right so i'll do the
f matrix again which is this
so the full set of shares and then we're
going to talk about what the
active shares are
so this is the full set of shares i just
appended
the hash calls at the bottom of this
vector
so it's pretty easy to see that if you
apply the identity here you get exactly
this
and
now i'm going to talk about green and
blue again so the garbling matrix the g
matrix
if i'm the evaluator what i get is
two input labels let's say a zero b one
and what i can do is i can
hash the
concatenation of them and i get this and
if you combine green and blue you get
this g matrix meaning
the active shares the active
view of the evaluator
and then you just compute a linear
combination you get in this case a zero
which is the correct output
yeah so the linear combination that you
apply is zero zero
zero
one zero zero one
and you sum it up you get c0
okay this is for a specific input for
general input so for any a and b there
are the inputs to the wires i can
describe the same thing so this is don't
worry the same thing i just replace
ones and zeros with symbolic a's and b's
so if a is zero here you get a one so
you get a zero
and so on
um
it's a very convenient
way to express all these four
matrices at once
because essentially we can argue
about some linear properties of this
matrix and then i'll show you something
interesting
so if you look at this matrix we say
that you have linear reconstruction if
the correct output wire label
is
in the span of the green and the blue
so the view of the evaluator spans the
correct output wire
and we say that
if the other output wire is not in the
span
you get something called linear privacy
and our theorem says
these two properties are enough for
simulation-based security
so
essentially write down your favorite
scheme in a matrix notation
fit it to a computer that evaluates
these two properties you get simulation
based security
good i'm not going to show that these
two properties hold on this scheme
but uh we can warm up in another way
so
yeah
and if you have different types of gates
that's fine just you need to show all
each of the different types of gates you
bring together
uh
you have to yes yes that happens
yeah
it's uh
you get some sort of possibility of this
of the gates in uh
yeah it's uh it's true
okay so
i'm gonna show that the half gates paper
is secure it's gonna be a one slide
proof
um so the half gates
had this
brilliant idea that
essentially if you secret share the
input between the garbler and the
evaluator
you can do
better
than
anything
so
remember va is going to be what mike
called the color bit it's known to the
evaluator and
it's nothing but the xor of the input
and the permutation bit that is chosen
by the gobbler
so it turns out that
the g matrix so the view of the
evaluator is the green and blue
uh
part of this matrix i omitted the vector
that is multiplied by
this but it's uh
it's not very important if you're
curious i can tell you what it is in one
second
um okay so
let's prove security so
i want to show these two properties
and
but first notice that the
output wires share a lot of entries
meaning they start with zero zero and
they end with one one zero zero
now we do some easy linear algebra to
show that the two properties old if you
don't want to follow it's okay you just
it's easy
um okay so let's look at look at the
second entry okay so now i'm going to
write a linear combination of the green
and blue
so i can't use red and purple
therefore i write this simple symbol
here just saying it's not allowed
i have to generate a zero at the second
entry just using green and blue
green here is a one and there's just one
of them
therefore i have to multiply that row by
zero if i want to have a zero in the
second entry
um okay so let's
check other properties like
this one and this zero
so this 0 means that this
has to be multiplied by va and this has
to be multiplied by 1 if i want to get a
1 here so this will happen
with a similar reasoning
this will happen and i have a carry here
of vb
because i'm multiplying this row by vb
therefore i get a vb as a result how do
you cancel that you just multiply by vb
the first row
good so what i showed is that
any linear combination that starts with
0 0 1 1 0 0 is this there's just one
what is the
question mark
you do some math it's the
red part it's not the purple one this
shows both
correctness and security
done you don't have to do anything else
good so let's move on
this is a good starting point
look at this
here
we are reconstructing a times b plus pa
pb
which is
quadratic
in a b
just by a linear function
from the evaluator's perspective on pb
and pa
this is a very good
thing
it's uh so you can observe that
you can obtain a times b plus this in a
clever way if you use this garbled huff
gate garbling essentially what they do
is they reveal a one-time pad
of the inputs the color bit
and then they can reconstruct
this
quantity
linearly in pa and pb
it's very very similar to beaver's
circuit randomization
and it can be extended to any polynomial
relation and this is
how our scheme works you use this
general technique
i can show you now
a matrix for garbling
this polynomial so this is how our
scheme will
garble a and b plus xor a and c xor in
blah blah blah
so
um i'm not going to do the math but you
can trust me
the two properties hold
and
what is interesting about this is that
we have four blue rows so
four rows
good
in general for a quadratic polynomial we
have that
essentially the number of rows we use to
garble is the number of variables
in the early example i showed four
rows for this
and if you compare to a trivial circuit
that computes the same function and you
apply the half gates paper you get 12
rows
so essentially if you were given the
circuit a and b x or blah blah blah
you would circumvent the lower bound
however
however
you can optimize the circuit
so
you can have a circuit with just two
ends and then you get exactly the same
complexity
so
that's uh kind of interesting
in general
for a quadratic polynomial there is a
paper by
um merelyn schnorr
uh that says that in a worst case
scenario you can guar you can
take a polynomial of degree two in and
variables
and just use m and gates where m is the
number of variables divided by two which
shows that
the performance of our scheme
and
the half gate via this best
circuit
is the same
um
morin
that's not the computation
what do you mean
the circle with the mn so it says some
depth right what's the depth of your
combination
um
well you take the
function as expressed as a polynomial
and this will be just uh
one matrix so
uh you the garbler just applies this
matrix it's uh
the size i can tell you this as it's
kind of a bit so it's better i mean
your scheme looks better so
yeah uh so this
the h
it depends on what you mean by
better there are some metrics for which
it's better
in ours
so it's better in one sense that is very
very important and i will mention it at
the end also which is the
essentially parallel use of hash
functions
there's also another thing that is maybe
minor that if you want to
compute the best circuit it needs some
time it's like
number of variables cubed
i don't know if that matters but anyway
uh it's something else
okay
so
that's a good question
in general
we have that
you can garble any polynomial of degree
d in n variables
with this communication complexity
uh so it means that if you're given this
polynomial
you'll get this
if you want to use the half gates you
have to find a circuit for it
and
it will have a number of ends and double
the amount of that will be the number of
rows that you are needed
um
so we have a result that says that for
random constant constant degree
polynomials over n variables
um essentially
it's better to just garble it via our
scheme than finding a circuit and then
using the half gates because
it's not clear how to find a good
circuit for that metric
but
if there are methods that allow you to
improve
the situation might change
so
it's not very clear
in
very general terms for commun
communication complexity but there are
some examples where we are better today
um yeah and i think
i'm running out of time so i'll conclude
with these
with a summary
what i talked about is a new framework
simple spam pro simple spend properties
imply simulation based security
i showed you a new boolean garbling
scheme
that has
nice properties the one i didn't talk
about but claudio hinted is this
parallelism parallelizability
so
the calls to the random oracle are done
statically for each unit
so if if you have a big unit you get
much better paralyzability
it will perform maybe worse in terms of
uh communication complexity but as i
said earlier it's not a clear
situation
what it didn't tell you about is that we
also can extend this to
arithmetic circuits and we have a
an interesting result for
small finite fields uh i mean it's a
general arithmetic
arithmetic garbling scheme but it
performs very well for small fields
and we also have an extension for
general mpc that uses
uh
beaver based
approaches like speeds or
these things
and then so this is all done
there are some ideas about non-linear
garbling and
i'm very happy to talk about
these if you're interested this is
the ideas are summarized by these two
pictures and if you're interested we can
talk about this
yeah
thanks
questions
so the arithmetic garbling schemes that
it
performs well for small finite fields so
what what what did you mean what's the
performance here and so um
i'm still talking about the size of the
garbled circuit
one method you can think
to garble
arithmetically is
convert it into a binary circuit and
then garble
if you do that
essentially
our scheme compares better if this if
the field is small
yeah
the
size of the circuit depends linearly on
the size of the field and this can be
bad you have to generate like a you know
a label for each of the field elements
or something like that um
sort of you don't have to do it
explicitly but it turns out that it will
be a bottleneck at the end exactly what
you said will be a bottleneck yeah
okay thank you